Laugh Tale and the one piece have been swallowed
by a gigantic island whale, one of Laboon's
brothers, who took a big chunk out of Jaya,
where there is now this big whole.
That Whale has been trapped by the world government
at the bottom of the giant whirlpool between
the three gates of justice and the three most
guarded government facilities in the world.
What gets you to that conclusion is that Whales
in One Piece always, ALWAYS appear whenever
Laugh Tale and the one piece are mentioned.
Or to be more precise, I realized that whales
guide Luffy and the straw hats towards the
right direction.
This starts as early as chapter 8, where we
see a whale fountain in Orange Town, just
as Nami acquires the map of the grand line
from Buggy.
Then, we have arguably the most important
scene in the entire story, as we meet Laboon
at the entrance of said grand line.
[] I just love that whale.
So cute.
Now, I personally am CONVINCED, that Laboon
is the key to figuring out the true nature
of laugh tale.
First of all, the whale is once again connected
to finding the right direction to laugh tale,
because it is here where the straw hats get
the log pose from Crocus, who later turns
out has been a member of the Roger pirates
himself who has actually been to laugh tale.
Something I still consider to be one of the
most underrated reveals in the entire story.
Crocus not only explains to the crew how to
navigate the grand line properly, but more
importantly is the first one to reveal the
name of the final island, laugh tale.
What's up my name is Manu and I cant even
begin to tell you how excited I am about this
theory today.
The more I looked into it, the more it blew
my mind.
Now I highly doubt Crocus revels this info
to anyone who tries to enter the grand line.
In fact he did so, only after Luffy managed
to befriend Laboon and keep him from hitting
his head against the red line.
However, If you have watched any of my other
videos, you will know that I don't believe
this to be a simply act of kindness.
I strongly believe that Crocus was placed
at the entrance to the grand line by his former
captain Roger to wait for the right person
to find Laugh Tale and the One PIece.
Not only does Luffy say the same things as
Roger and is incredibly kind and caring towards
Laboon, but he also wears the straw hat, that
used to belong to Roger, which immediately
tells crocus that this is the man they have
been waiting for.
That is why he tells Luffy about laugh tale.
But we're not done with Laboon.
Because the first thing that happens to the
straw hats when entering the grand line is
getting swallowed by this enormous whale.
It'a a reference to the classic story trope
of Jonah and the whale, that can for example
also be found in Pinocchio, who also gets
swallowed by a whale and who leaves the whale
a changed person.
Similarly, I think it's more than fair to
say that the straw hats leave Laboon changed,
now worthy of sailing towards the final island.
Laboon himself is so gigantic, that, as you
hopefully remember, he actually has an island
INSIDE of him, from where crocus tries to
take care of him, the first island of the
grand line.
This is where the idea comes from that the
last island might be inside a whale as well.
As far as I know, people have made the connection
between whales and Laugh Tale quite early,
but this theory in particular stems from my
favorite Japanese one piece YouTuber Yuderon,
who's ideas I have already talked about in
two other massive videos.
According to Yuderon, and I personally 100%
believe that he's spot on with this, Eiichiro
Oda, the author of One Piece, writes his story
according to three core principles.
Symbolism, Two sides of the same coin and
word plays.
The symbol here is of course the whale that
represents the journey to Laugh tale, but
what I want you to focus on is the second
concept.
Oda takes elements and concepts of before
the time skip, and reintroduces them after
the time skip in an inverted or mirrored way.
Which I find an ingeniously smart way to structure
a long-format story like one piece.
If you want to learn more about this, I suggest
you check out my other videos with Yuderon
on this topic, but here's A quick example
to illustrate this:
Alabasta and dressrosa are both arcs about
a warlord that rules from the shadow over
a country.
Both are manipulative, run an underground
organisation and have to be exposed and defeated
by Luffy.
Both times we have a princess that tries to
help her country.
The kings of the countries are unable to help
their people.
The marines are there to interfere, but finally
relaize that Luffy is trying to help.
And much much more.
Well the argument here, is that the first
and last island of the grand line will also
mirror each other.
An island inside a giant whale.
Not only do we know right from the start,
that this is actually possible, but the person
who created the island actually has been to
laugh tale itself.
So to me at least, it would make a ton of
sense, if Crocus got inspiration for this
from the final island itself.
Don't you think?
Then, there's the name of Laboon's species.
He is a literal island whale.
That felt very much like in your face writing
by Oda-sensei once I started to look at that
scene again from this perspective.
And we know that laboon is still relatively
young in island whale years, so there most
likely are even larger relatives of his out
there.
Now in general, if you love mythology and
fantasy as much as I do, you will probably
know that the concept of giant whales with
islands is a very famous trope.
Tales of gigantuous whales with islands on
their back are very common and part of folk
lore all over the world.
So it's not exactly mysterious where Oda-sensei
might have gotten this idea from.
I have even more to say about Laboon, but
let's look at the other whale symbolism throughout
one piece first.
If you look closely, we have small whales
engraved in the gates of the palace in alabasta,
that is tied close to the void century, one
of the ancient weapons and is right above
the hidden poneglyph.
Similarly, there are whales engraved on the
giant golden bell in the lost city of shandora.
Not only is this city connected to the ancient
kingdom, but according to the big theory of
Yuderon, actually was part of the ancient
kingdom on Jaya.
Oh and doesn't this on top here look a lot
like a monkey with a straw hat to you?
Just saying.
Then, we have whitebeards ship, the Moby dick
appearing at Marineford, as the emperor declares
that the one piece is real [].
We see whales in chapter 604, just before
crossing the red line and reaching fishman
island, that is connected to joy boy and is
home to one of the ancient weapons.
And by the way, there are also whales, when
robin deciphers the poneglyph there.
[]
Then, after leaving fishman island and entering
the new world, the straw hats are welcomed
by a pod of island whales, mirroring their
encounter with laboon and marking their progress
towards finding the last island.
After that it takes a while for a whale to
appear again, but it finally happens on Zou,
where there is a giant whale shaped tree,
that contains the first road poneglyph pointing
the direction to laugh tale.
[] I think its also worth mentioning, that
Zunesha herself is connected to the whale
theory very closely.
I think Oda took the classic idea of a whale
with an island on its back and turned it into
an elephant, that is also closely connected
to the void century.
It proves to me, that having a giant creature
that harbours an entire island is very much
possible.
Zuneshia has been tasked with walking to a
certain location as punishment for her sin,
so could she be looking for a giant whale?
Also I just realized, that the road poneglyph
is literally inside the giant whale again.
Almost too obvious Oda-sensei.
So as you can see, the whale symbol is closely
connected to anything to do with the ancient
kingdom and the void century.
Alabasta, shandora, Fishman island, Zou - the
only place left is Wano.
But, there haven't been any whales on Wano
have there?
You might like this one.
Take a look at the Kozuki crest.
Of course the main theme here is the crane
in the middle.
But what do you think about the crossbones
around it?
To me, they look a lot like whale fins diving
into the sea.
Very hard to unsee, am I right?
Now this might just be a way for Oda, to connect
all these places, but I think it's quite possible
that the whale itself was the symbol of the
ancient kingdom.
I mean the chapter itself is titled 'Inside
the whale'.
But let's get back to the giant whale that
holds laugh tale.
Because there is a lot more evidence that
there is a twin whale to laboon, another whale
just like him, that has also eaten an entire
island.
First of all, the place where Laboon was introduced
is called Twin Capes.
Then have the giant kraken surume who lives
at the bottom of the ocean and who has a brother,
that was held hostage by Holy and thus forced
him to comply.
Could this hint at Laboon's relative being
held hostage by the world government?
We also get this interesting line by the sea
kings.
[]
But the most important chapter, after the
encounter with Laboon, is 654, where the straw
hats arrive in the new world.
The chapter starts with Luffy catching a fish
that is swallowed another fish, swallowed
by an even larger fish.
The chapter is titled a pod of whales and
on the cover features the twins moz and kiwi
from water seven, the risky brothers as well
as Lola, who we now know also has a twin sister
with chiffon.
Oh and the chapter also features an enormous
whirlpool, that transports the straw hats
right to a huge pod of island whales.
And this is where things get really interesting,
as you can see, I cant stop grinning when
thinking about it.
In this same chapter, we get reminded that
Laboon is closely tied to one of the straw
hats in particular.
Brook, the musician of the crew, who had this
tear-jerking flashback with
the whale.
[] In this chapter, Brook of course mistakes
the whales for lagoon and starts singing the
song that always made laboon happy when he
heard it.
Bink's sake.
And to my absolute astonishment, now that
I'm reading this again, the other island whales
recognise this song and actually start singing
as well, which is why they start carrying
the sunny safely to the surface.
Now in case you don't know why this is so
important, Binks sake is heavily connected
to Laugh Tale as well.
The song literally ends with the phrase 'Never-Ending,
Ever-wandering, Our funny Traveling tale!',
using the Japanese kanji for laugh and tale.
I actually made an entire video analysing
this song, that contains hints about the Kozuki,
the dawn of the world and much much more.
Now I personally came to conclusion that Laugh
Tale might be the underworld, where the crew
would have to descend to.
But now I actually believe that the underworld
is actually the bottom of the ocean, Davy
Jone's locker, the inside of a giant island
whale, to which the crew will have to descend.
The ever-wandering laugh tale.
That sounds a lot like a moving living thing,
similar to zuneshia.
As you know from Luffy, Ace and Sabo, Sake
is a sign of brotherhood.
So delivering binks sake to one of lagoons
brothers might be the promise that joy boy
made to the mermaid princess and that he could
never keep.
The theme of siblings is closely connected
to the whales after all.
There are also other lines in the song that
would fit well to laugh tale being under water.
'If you lose your nerve this breath could
be your last.
But if you just hold on, The morning sun will
rise.'
Holding your breath to go under water.
There is also Tsumugi no sato yo.
Tsumugi no sato is the village of spinning.
I originally thought that this refers to the
Kozuki spinning the history into the poneglyph.
This is supported by 'The birds sing as they
draw circles in the sky!'
TO me that was probably the Kozuki crest,
but if Yuderon's idea is true and the whale
is trapped in the giant whirlpool between
the gates of justice, the spinning village
could literally be laugh tale caught in a
giant whirlpool, ever-moving.
Before I tell you another crazy detail, if
you enjoy this type of content, the secret
to getting more of this every single week
is subscribing to the channel.
Another crazy detail I found, is that there
is actually a Yokai in Japanese mythology
called Bake-Kujira, a giant living whale skeleton.
Now, Binks sake ends with, 'Doesn't matter
who you are, Someday you'll just be bones.
Never-Ending, Ever-wandering, Our funny Traveling
tale!'
And we literally have brook, a living skeleton
that is connected to the island whales.
Not sure if that's the direction Oda would
take this, but it might be relevant as well.
But basically, the idea is, that a giant whale,
bit of laugh tale from Jaya 800 years ago
to protect whatever was there, but was trapped
by Imu and the government between 3 gates
of justice at the bottom of the sea, where
it can not escape.
Which might be the reason why shanks and his
men all haven't eaten devil fruits, so they
can go and visit.
After all shanks would well know how to get
to laugh tale, even if he stayed behind with
Buggy.
Now as fascinating as this theory is, if you
really want to blow your own mind and take
it to the next level, this isn’t enough
on its own.
There is actually an absolutley crazy theory
about the true nature of laugh tale and the
ancient kingdom, that has changed how people
see one piece forever.
And that’s why you really shouldnt ignore
this video, because it’s twice as exciting
as the whale theory and in combination with
it will make you feel like you’ve figured
out One Piece.